I'm in Sydney Australia
and I'm here at the harbour and I'm
really excited to see the bridge Sydney
Harbour Bridge and particularly excited
because I used to live in Newcastle upon
Tyne in the northeast of England where
they had the prototype of this bridge a
smaller one where they were trying out
the design the same shape design but not
as wide because the River Tyne in
Newcastle is not as wide as the harbour
is here and I was talking to Brady about
the bridge and he wanted to know why on
earth would you build a bridge out of
steel which is easily corroded by salt
from the sea and it rusts with oxygen in
the air when it's wet why wouldn't you
build it from concrete or something
that's less liable to corrode and the
answer is that steel is so much stronger
now you can't just use pure iron because
pure iron is rather soft and with the
structure as big as this it would Bend
under its own weight but steel which is
a mixture of iron with a small amount of
carbon and sometimes some other metals
as well it's very very strong steel
swords are much better than iron swords
don't break when you hit your enemy
which can be quite embarrassing if
you're in the middle of a fight and so
steel is a really good material to build
something like this bridge and this
bridge I looked up has more than 58,000
tonnes of steel in it at the same time
you've got to join the steel together in
modern bridges they use a technique
called welding where they heat the steel
to a high temperature and essentially
melts the edges together so it becomes
one solid piece of metal
here they used a slightly older
technique called riveting you make a
hole through the two pieces you want to
join and put a steel or iron rod through
it and then you bang the two ends of the
rod so they form heads like the head on
the screw and that holds the things
together and it holds it very rigidly
there's an expression in English being
riveted which means really fixed on
something like I hope you're riveted on
my videos now with just to stress how
strongly a rivet will hold things
together there's still the question of
rusting because the steel when it gets
wet will react with oxygen in the air so
you have to paint it and if you have a
really big bridge you paint it all the
time you have a gang of workers who
start painting at one end and by the
time they've got to the other end it's
time to start again and I guess that
that's what they do here as well there
are several bridges in the UK where
they're constantly painting painting
puts a layer over the surface of the
iron and essentially stops the oxygen
getting to it
the alternative strategy is to put
pieces of some metal that corrodes more
recently like zinc and then the zinc
arose preferentially this is what
happens where you have galvanized iron
the sort of iron that you put on sheds
and buildings in the country where you
have iron covered by a thin layer of
zinc and the zinc corrodes away but it
corrodes sufficiently slowly that the
roof exists as long as you need it any
metal when you heat it up expands incase
of a road it gets longer
and obviously the longer the rod the
more it'll expand this is a big problem
in railway lines if you don't allow for
expansion when the weather's hot the
railway lines Bend and buckle and the
trains fall off and with a bridge it's
even worse so what you have to do
normally is that you fix one end of the
bridge and the other end of the bridge
is on rollers so when the bridge gets
hot and expands it physically moves on
the rollers backwards and forwards and
the precise way that the rollers are
implemented differs from each bridge I
don't know whether this bridge actually
uses rollers or it has some other sort
of expansion joints and it's an
interesting point because building a
bridge is an engineering problem and
engineering is different from science
because often there several different
solutions to the same problem in
engineering you just have to look at all
sorts of different sorts of cars which
all are solving the problem how do you
move from one place to another in
science there's usually only one answer
why do two hydrogen atoms bond together
and you've either got the right answer
or not
I was pretty impressed when I first saw
the bridge it's always a bit difficult
when you've seen something in pictures
so many times to know what it'll be like
I was surprised that there were so many
buildings and things around it because I
suppose in photos people usually try and
show it isolated